what's happening you bad [__]
greetings from podcastville
it's tuesday january 12th let me tell
you something from jersey
i'm letting you know draftkings it's
where it's at
the joint is brought to you by
[__] draftkings
i don't know if you watch football this
weekend you know there are some pushes
whatnot a couple upsets but there's
money to be made
sports are in full swing right now
there's no shortage of action
you got college basketball you got pro
basketball you got nfl football i mean
jesus [__] christ
to celebrate the playoffs draftkings
is giving all new players a great offer
grab a pen
get ready for this one [__] this
weekend bet on any football game at 100
to 1 odds
that's right all you got to do is bet a
dollar on any football game this weekend
for a chance to win 100 bucks plus
the basketball season has tipped off so
head to the
draftkings app right now and check out
that daily odds boost
download the top rated draftkings
sportsbook app
today right now while you're [__]
around use promo code
joey when you sign up to get 100 to one
odds
on any football team this weekend that's
coach joey
for new players to get a shot at 100 on
any football game this weekend do you
understand
what i'm [__] offering you
[__] for a limited time
only at draftkings sportsbook now here's
the part the lawyers make me say you
know it already
got to be 21 or older if you're younger
than 21 go [__] yourself go play
dice on a quarter or something you
shouldn't be [__] gambling indiana
pennsylvania tennessee colorado
you're all in restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gambling problem
there's help call 1-800 gambler
if you're in indiana call 1-809 with it
but if we're gambling like a
[__] it's draftking sportsbook
halftime
use code joey and cash it on this deal
the joint is also brought to you by zip
recruiter for a lot of us our home is
now more than just
our home it's our [__] office we do
everything out of the house
record gym school [__]
you know jesus christ if you're a
business owner
or manage people these days your home
might also be your hiring office
that's where zip recruiter comes in you
don't want nobody coming over the house
to talk to you about a [__] job
zip recruiter makes hiring faster and
easier because you can do it all at one
convenient place
ziprecruiter.com church no matter where
you're hiring from
zip recruiter does the work for you and
right now
try zip recruiter for free enjoy what
are you talking about
for free go to ziprecruiter.com
church c-h-u-r-c-h that ziprecruiter.com
church c-h-u-r-c-h and all you need is
wi-fi to try it for free
that easy go to ziprecruiter.com
church zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire
the joint is also brought to you by one
of my personal favorite cbd lion for the
last two days
i've been living off this two weeks
before my surgery i stopped taking baby
aspirin i stopped eating the
cbd gummies i stopped it all because i
wanted it to hit me harder
after the surgery i gotta tell you
something after two days i eat gummies
for pain management and then i pop a
pain pill i eat gummies for pain
management
then i got uh a pain pill that's been my
schedule the last two days i've been
rubbing this on my knee
cbd line is exceptional whether it's a
kinesiology tape
bathing a bath ball in your tub vapor
however you want to put cbd in
cbd line is going to help you go to cbd
line right now
and look at the third party lab test
results
and read read about terpenes read about
cbn
read about what's available to you and
you don't know about
okay so go to cbdline.com and press in
joey and get 20 off delivered right to
your [__] crib who does that for you
nobody that's how we're starting off the
year all right that's it and that's that
let's get this [__] party started
candles lit you little dirty [__]
beautiful
look who it is
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's tuesday the 12th
first off i'm very sorry we had to move
the podcast from monday to tuesday
uh yesterday it was just too heavy of it
of the day
i had physical therapy i had a bunch of
[__] you know
so uh we got to do it at night i'm happy
i'm here thank you
for all the tweets and the facebook
messages and the patreon messages
you guys headed out of the park when i
got out of surgery
i looked on my computer i'm like these
[__] they're uh
relentless i was in so much [__] pain
but hey
it was a great weekend i got it over
with
if you guys know anything about me uh
[__] i hate doctors in hospitals more
than i hate broccoli you know what i'm
saying like broccoli and cauliflower
you show up with broccoli around me i
walk right out of the [__] room i
hate how it [__] smells
but i [__] hate the whole experience
but once i'm in the car
i had to do this i had to do this just
to get healthier you know
and it was so funny what came to me in
the hospital so
thursday night you know i didn't know my
surgery time
i had no idea what my surgery time was
they said they'd call after four on
thursday and tell me which is like what
the [__]
you know i'm in suspense all [__] day
mercy comes home from school by 4 30. my
wife
they come downstairs they come to the
garage we're talking downstairs
mercy's sitting on the steps terry's
sitting in the step under her
and they called and they were like you
gotta be in at nine o'clock
your surgery is scheduled for ten um
we're not recommending it but we should
we we
understand if you want to go home but
we're recommending that you stay the
night so we could watch you we have
better eyes on you blah blah blah
i got off the phone with them and i told
my wife and mercy you know i go yeah
they don't want me to stay
and also my daughter's face just went
pale
and she started crying you know i was
gonna miss her birthday i mean it was
[__] terrible
i got upset and then uh you know i
calmed it down i talked to her a little
bit
she was scared she was scared for her
dad you know it broke my [__] heart
uh so what we did was we got a birthday
cake thursday night
and we celebrated her birthday a little
carvel cake we each had a little piece
and we hung out all night i let her stay
up late with me and uh
you know i was really concerned about it
she just doesn't like that [__] at all
she doesn't even like when i change the
setting and she saw the stitches last
night she ran out she don't like none of
that [__] at all
she wouldn't even pick me up at the
hospital like she's like i don't want to
see dad like that
so i can't tell you how i felt all
weekend
uh the surgery you know i mean
they tried to stick the needle in my
hand first the intravenous and it didn't
work
i almost fainted i went into my arm nice
and [__]
uh whatever the little nurse's assistant
great guy he's like i've been doing this
for nine years i've never seen a man
sweat so much
i mean i was sweating [__] profusely
that i put the bed upside down
so the blood could go to my head but
after that i gotta be honest it was
great
then they hit you with a couple by the
ways they're like this anesthesiology is
going to come in nice guy
comes in sweetheart up a guy everybody
was a sweetheart
so that at least soothed my [__]
nerves you guys know i'm a nervous
[__] dude
the anesthesiologist guy came in and he
goes listen we're gonna put you out and
[__] but before you go out
we gotta do an epidural shot in your
[__] spine
i'm like are you [__] kidding me now
a week earlier new year's eve i was at a
house and one of the chicks is a dirt a
a nurse is a sick like a doctor's
assistant
a little higher than a nurse and she
goes you know they're gonna give you an
epidural block right and i'm like
i [__] hope not i saw my wife get one
and i saw my ex-wife i listened to this
when i had my first kid in 1990
my wife was one of those [__] hippie
chicks and she's like i'm gonna have the
baby natural you know all that [__]
after one hour at the natural place she
cracked
when they put that up with and i walked
into the room and i saw the blood coming
out of her back
from the needle and i went down that's
what i
that's what i associate an epidural
block with and then about two years ago
my wife's back was hurting her and she
did the wrong
joe rogan treatment and they had to do
an epidural blocked and i went with her
that's what husbands do
and i was holding onto a hand i could
feel the pain so when they told me at
the door
blocked dog i started looking at my
sneakers you know what i'm saying like
[__] this [__] i didn't get no needle
but he goes i give you my word
you're going to be so [__] numb at
that point
you're not even going to feel it so when
they got me all prepped up but
everything guys i gotta tell you the
most embarrassing thing
i'm old my dick has shrunk over the
years
but friday my dick was the smallest it's
ever been in 50 [__] seven and a half
years
it went all the way in i don't know if
it was the fear
the [__] drugs they put into me so
i'm on the operating table
and i tell the guy right before they
shoot me with the epidural block
dude was cuban the guy that rolled me in
he goes listen
uh i go i gotta pee
and he goes i don't worry about that if
you have to pee during the procedure
we'll stick a stick of tube in your dick
and we'll take it out of your dick that
way and i go listen
i'm doing enough today ain't nobody's
sticking no tubes in my [__] dick
let's just do this right now
so i got up and they gave a girl a
bottle
and i had to hold my inch dick it was
this [__] big
the turtleneck just the wrapping around
my dick
it was a nightmare pulling the skin back
and trying to pee into the [__]
bottle
i peed on my gown i mean it was a
[__] nightmare guys
i remember them sticking a little prick
in my back and i [__] gave a little
thing
and that's it i wish i remember what
happened after that i blacked out i
don't know if i called them [__]
i told them make america great again i
don't know what i [__] happened after
that all i know
is that they turned the lights off at 5
at 10
30 and they were wheeling me out and
when i got into the recovery room
it was [__] four o'clock and guys
i had a pain because the epidural block
wore off after two hours the surgery
lasted four
so i woke up to [__] a pain
that you couldn't even imagine they even
had to shut off a nerve in my leg
they shut off a nerve in your leg and
then they turn it back on or something
to eliminate the pain the dude's like
i'll leave it off he goes i know what
you're going through
so they started shooting me with a bunch
of [__]
demerol once i got the demo i was all
right and you know me i'm like give me
because you want me to tell you what the
sad thing about this is guys guys i
don't eat this [__]
but my tolerance is high my street
tolerance is high so
they shot me they shot me with god do
do whatever the [__] it is damn you with
two narcos
and two [__] percocets and i still
had pain
i was on fire though i was on [__]
fire i was [__] up as a can of worms
i sat in recovery for like [__] an
hour just looking there was nobody in
there it was just me in recovery and
some other poor bastard on the other
side
they fixed his foot his foot was all
[__] up i'm looking at him he's
looking at me that's all we could do the
whole time in [__] recovery
and then uh they're like you ready to go
up to your room and they
put me up in my [__] room i was
starving at that point
they hit me with the [__] pasta
it wasn't bad with a couple shrimp in it
but they gave me broccoli so that pissed
me off a breadstick
non-sugarless applesauce and [__]
apple juice tremendous
dinner i ate it now i had 300 milligrams
i had three i that's my this they called
to tell me to bring my sleep apnea
machine also
so i had to bring my road sleep apnea
machine i have two of the same machines
i have one for the house and one i would
use for the road
so i went into the bag and i haven't
used that bag
since february 28th i haven't looked in
that bag oh my lord i looked in that bag
the other night 20 to life no parole
what was in that bag they would throw me
under the [__] jail
i found [__] in that bag i found two
hits of acid
paper acid because i always put that bag
together
so if i got stuck in an airport i
wouldn't be bored and upset
so there was edibles in there there was
[__]
anxiety medication in there [__]
edibles
i mean there was everything in there
there was a vapor pen in there i hadn't
even seen
when was the last time you never saw me
smoke a [__] paper pen there was a
man
come back from the acid church who the
[__] no no
because i just used it i just used it
february 28th
this is a compartment i had in there for
emergency stuff hearing aid batteries
blood in case you get stuck one night at
a hotel blood pressure medication
all my medication all my vitamins
everything is in there
when i found those two hits a little
paper acid
i go that's where you've been i lost you
a year ago you [__]
so i cleaned out the bag but i also
found three 200 milligrams
i found edibles in there i found old
edibles in that
are they good stuff i threw the cookie
away i wouldn't give the cookie delete
you know what i'm saying i gave lee
molded stars before we found those
molded stars
we ate those [__] things you know us
we build our immune system we don't give
a [__]
so uh i went up to my room man they fed
me dinner
and i got to be honest with you i
thought i was really going to be unhappy
the whole night and be miserable i mean
i missed my daughter
i missed my wife i gave my nurse
a [__] nickname blood pressure
because that's all that [__] would do
is raise my blood pressure every time
she came in it was to
bust my balls one night i the first
night
actually you know i couldn't sleep i was
in the hospital and i was prepared for
it
i was like i'm not gonna sleep so i'm
going to watch [__] catch up on some
videos
watch some old concerts you know maybe
i'll pop an edible but i told the emerge
the recovery room check i go i got some
edibles
and she goes how strong are they go 200
she goes please don't do them in here
she goes please so i asked when they
gave me the dinner
i asked them for the the turkey sandwich
they always give you at the hospital
every turkey's every hospital gives you
a [__] turkey sandwich
so they gave me a turkey sandwich i left
that there to go with applesauce
just in case i did eat the edible at
night i had something to munch on the
middle night i brought some protein
powders with me
you know i always prepared some protein
things with me from on it on it has
these peanut butter protein bites that
are [__] tremendous
i brought like 10 of those with me and
you know what man i probably slept
three hours that night she came in i
finally at one point like four i put the
sleep apnea mask on just to
force myself to sleep you know this
[__] came in
and she goes mr diaz we're going to come
back and give you blood pressure
medication i go all right hurry up i'm
trying to go to sleep here
you [__] hour later she showed up i
go i'm just [__] falling asleep and
you got to come in and break my boss my
blood pressure
she loved it i kept calling her blood
pressure i had a little gay guy
that was her assistant the sweetest guy
he ever met
again i had to pee so they wanted me to
get up they're like it's time for you to
get up
you know you get up you know and i go
[__] yeah let's do this [__]
and i got up and the chick is behind me
and the little gay guy's in front of me
he's there like five minutes
i got my little inch dick in the
container
i'm trying to pee and this guy's looking
straight at me and i'm like
listen i've done a lot of crazy things i
can't pee in front of this gay guy
i just can't take my dick out and pee in
front of this gay guys i've showed my
dick to a thousand gay guys just to
torture him over the years
i'm 58 i i cannot oh yeah i would show
gay guys my dick all the time
take a look at this [__] uke of love
cox
but uh i followed him right to his face
i go dog i can't pee in front of you you
gotta abandon [__]
my [__] you got me all [__] up here
so he [__] went out uh and they told
me in the morning they would give me
physical therapy
and let me go they came they got me
they [__] uh nice little breakfast
scrambled eggs
nice bacon a corn muffin
like a doctor i got up i [__]
uh you know i can't watch tv in the
daytime but
whatever was on was on i was watching
something about the american mafia was
on or something on cnn
i was watching that and they came in
like they said you know the doctor told
me he was listen if you want to stay
you stay he goes if i was you
i'd let us watch you over the night i
have a uh
my my heart was slow you know i've
always said this on august 21st
when we got in the 19th i had a mild
heart attack because the cavity in my
chest hurt for three or four days
i said if it hurts past that i'll go to
the [__] doctor and it didn't hurt
past that so
i never went to the doctor but i'm still
to this day
convinced that i had a mild heart attack
i just didn't if i would have gone to
the hospital
and they would have drawn blood they
would have told me i would have had a
mild heart attack
so ever since that night my heart's been
beaten
kind of [__] slow so they were like
listen we're a little concerned
uh they were so concerned that a
cardiovascular
doctor came in at night and kind of
talked to me a little bit
but i could tell there was something he
wanted to tell me but since he's not my
heart doctor he couldn't tell me
but he gave me a card which proved to me
he wanted to tell me something
so i left him a message today to see if
he called me back personally and after
this whole thing's over
i'm switching hard doctors because i'm
sure i need a stent
or maybe for them to give me one of
those [__] jolts when they put those
electro things in your heart to get your
beat back down
so listen man i got a daughter you know
20 years ago i wouldn't have given a
[__] about this thing
i wouldn't have given a [__] about the
surgery i wouldn't have given a [__]
about anything
but you know what man i want to walk
around a great adventure with her i want
to be able to
walk around parks with her and take
hikes you know i'm a walker i'm from
north bergen new jersey
i think i got up the hill with a [__]
scooter no he had a [__]
walk i'm a walker so for me just to be
able to walk
eight minutes now that breaks my [__]
heart it's embarrassing
even two years ago when i was taken to
disneyland at one point i was like i'm
done terry
my knees are on [__] fire both of
them
so uh i'm gonna use a little cbd line
while we're here talking
i [__] uh if you want later on i
might take a picture and we can post it
for you
i don't want to show you the stitches i
made a little video for you guys
yesterday
but i made it in the wrong place i was
going to place up
just to show you the leg but you guys
seen enough horror with tom segura you
know what i'm saying
you guys have been doing enough with
uncle tom
so i just wanted to so what i'm doing
now is just putting the cbd
around the area because one place i have
a lot of pain in
is in the thigh so i just put the little
[__] thing on it blah blah blah
blah blah blah and here we go you bad
[__] that's how this works
this is what i'm trying to say there and
i mean the gummies to replace
i don't want to get listen at 58 if you
think i want to be one of those guys
right
now that gets caught up on pain pills i
can't do it
i already did my 27 year term with
cocaine
i can't be chasing pills right now so
i'll play the pain game a little bit
listen man think
it was so funny how in the hospital i'm
sitting and i'm like
i can't believe that in every aspect of
life
no matter what again i'm using plumbers
dentists doctors you know laborers
when you have pain it gets you to the
next level
it's amazing how sometimes we have to go
through pain to get to that next level
like yeah this is going to be great in
six weeks
but it's gonna that [__] physical
therapy today hurt so bad i had to take
a nap afterward for two hours i mean
walk by and i'm doing a little extra
everybody like i'm doing a little extra
you know like i've been walking you know
uh she tells me to get up
every hour on the hour you guys know for
years i've been
when i write i do 115 and i got to write
this weekend
because i was at peace i was at the
hospital so i
got half the chapter written so my deal
is coming through my deal i made to you
guys
i don't care about anything else this
year i just want to write that book i
could care less about stand-up comedy i
care about the podcast i care about
communicating with you guys
but stand-up comedy right now that
travels i just i'm not i have no i have
no interest i don't know why
especially what happened after
washington last week you know like i
just told jim florentine who was here
with his son to bring dinner and i said
to him uh
you know with comics what if you get on
a plane and you're going to kansas city
and when you land you go on twitter or
whatever and all of a sudden
there's a [__] war going on two
blocks from the comedy club or from your
hotel
you know i got a wife i got a kid
i'm not missing meals uh there's no
reason for me to go out there right now
it's too crazy it's not that i'm scared
i just don't want to
do something i don't have to there's no
why walk on landmines when you don't
have to you know
but uh it was just so weird how in every
[__]
i remember when i started comedy from 91
to 98 i was in pain because i was so bad
as a comic you've been in pain like
i was so bad as a comic and i wanted to
be good
then i was in pain you know but after i
got a little better and i started
getting you know
like in seattle was where i felt myself
becoming a comic
but you have to overcome pain to get to
the next level and like i said even with
this
there was a point today after that pt
lady left my whole leg was on [__]
fire
that podcast i put up in uh patreon
because i didn't give you this on monday
but i didn't want to leave my patreon
people on a [__] lurch
so i left them a little 22 minute joey
diaz project
just to let them know those 22 minutes
just from sitting here yesterday
and the chair going up against my thigh
made my legs swell up
so you know right now i'm comfortable if
i feel anything i'll get the [__] out of
here you know
you guys got to see me i look good i
look healthy you know i'm happy
i'm so happy i got this over with if you
guys knew the [__] i
am when it comes to this [__] um
half the anxiety i had left is gone
because
if i was gonna have anxiety was gonna be
last week between the two shows the
[__] needles
the echocardiogram the stress test
the stress test was [__] too
hanging lighty but i passed with flying
colors
uh it just was a great week
you know why because i did some i went
out of my comfort zone
i loved going out of my comfort zone in
the last eight months
i haven't gotten out of my comfort zone
there's been you know i haven't done
dick
i decided i could call bill burr and
follow him you know i'm saying like bill
do 10 minutes let me go up behind you
and be out of my comfort zone i got
nobody like nobody's doing dick
so i really haven't pushed my comfort
zone so
the surgery meant a lot more in a lot
different levels do you know what i'm
saying like it just wasn't a
uh a new knee it was a new step for me
even at 58 you know you still got to
grow so
would i do this 20 years ago if it
wasn't for that chick upstairs
i wouldn't have done none of this i
would have been dead from sleep apnea
already
she's the one that had to beg me to go
to the doctor
when uh the sleep apnea [__] uh
was dooming on me so i wouldn't even
have [__] done [__] if it wasn't for
her
and this is the real reason i tell you
guys this from my heart because
this is uncle joey's joint i always want
to be honest with you
her dad had this option when he was 50
and he didn't want to do his knees over
and he had a heart attack and now they
couldn't do the knees
so now he has a hard time walking i love
my father-in-law i love my in-laws
but my wife like pulled me aside and
she's like i don't want
what happened to my dad to happen to you
or something happens to your heart
then your heart isn't strong enough to
withdraw to you know
the surgery but i'll tell you one thing
that the doctor told me afterward
and the pt guy told me when they my
first bend
was 68 which i think the first deal they
measured was like a [__]
puerto rican protractor remember the
protractor you stab him
and you made a circle did you ever
protract protractor mike when you were a
kid they make you go through it
i thought they stopped teaching them
because they were no good when was the
last time you used a protractor to make
a certain
use in the fourth grade then you didn't
use them again who gives a [__] about a
protractor
but uh yeah the first day was 63 or
something and today was 70.
and one thing that the one lady said to
me she goes did you work out before this
and i go i really did
and i stretched every day and i did
puerto rican yoga every day you know
downward dogs
i did everything i could i went to the
gym three times a week
i got ready for this physically you know
last monday at the gym
i worked so hard i had a [__] anxiety
attack from picking up 45 pound plates
and just [__]
going up and down like a [__] baboon
but i wanted to be ready i wanted my
heart to be ready you know
i just over 50 lifting weights is the
fountain of youth
you know it just it takes care of so
many things
cortisol diabetes you know bone strength
you know [__]
muscles i mean it just does wonders for
you so i'm happy i did the work i'm
happy you guys supported me on it
and that's it man sometimes we got to do
it we don't got to do
this is going to have a positive result
i'm going to have an easier time on
stage you know i always have
i was never having a hard time on stage
just after i went back to the after the
two shows
after two hours of standing i'd go back
to my room and i'd have to put my leg up
with [__] ice i didn't tell people
that as i was going on
but you know this will be a lot better
for me so i'll be a lot better comic
i'll be healthier this will let me move
more maybe start running again you guys
know i love to run i haven't run since i
got out of prison
i used to love to run i used to do the
3ks and [__] in boulder
you know i'm all about that [__] but now
on a lighter note
something happened last night i woke up
in the middle of night to a very
very very disturbing [__]
message i uh had watched uh
the king of staten island you know and
i loved it you know i'm a big pete
davidson fan pete's a great kid
uh and i watched bill burr and [__]
bill burr was great that movie
i mean i've watched bill grow over the
years it was just great to watch that
movie every scene he was in
you know and what's her name the chick
that plays the mother
i forget the name now she made a
comeback with the wrestler
she played uh pete davidson's mother in
the
movie that lady won a [__] oscar for
[__] my cousin benny didn't she
was telling her marissa told me i think
she wanted oscar
so here's a comic a comedy store comic
let's throw that in
going up against marissa thomas and you
couldn't tell the [__] difference
he's great in the mandalorian oh he's
great now i haven't watched the
mandalorian you know what
you know i don't like nothing out of
space [__] but uh
this [__] was he [__] he [__]
rocked my world so hard
that i text him and i put the phone down
and i fell asleep
and i woke up like a [__] 2 30 in the
morning
and i got a text back from him like he
was he was happy to hear from me which i
was in shock
and i had a phone call missed and a
message from redman
telling me that jeff scott had died for
you people who don't know who jeff scott
is i know you've seen
a thousand things on facebook and
twitter today
jessica was a piano player at the
[__] comedy store
great guy i guess he died of a heart
attack at 58
uh december 18th or december no i'm
gonna be december 18th
his birthday he turned 58 december 18th
or something like that
this is my tribute to jeff uh and i'm
going to be honest
with you guys about a lot of things in
this conversation
because whenever there's death you got
to have a little humor to it
jeff was a great guy jeff caught hiv
in the 80s and i get to the comedy store
you know when you get to the comedy
store you want to be friends with people
people ask you if you want to get high
yeah you know
and one day he came up to me he goes joe
you want to get high and i love jeff i'm
like yeah jeff let's go let's get out i
didn't care i didn't being gay or
whatever i didn't
had nothing to do with me and we smoked
a joint after the joint he looked at me
because you know i got hiv right and i'm
like
well i was like really spit out of my
mouth but it didn't really you know i
know i couldn't get hiv from smoking a
joint with jeff but
it was just weird that after we smoked a
joint you just happened to drop that
bomb on me
but it made me love him more this
happened in 97
and it made me love him more jeff worked
at the store i think six nights a week
he watched every comic in that room
and he had been there for i don't know
how many years 25 years plus
he had seen everybody you know
he pulled me aside when i came back to
the comedy store in 2014.
and after he saw my first setback
he pulled me aside this is my secret to
you guys this is my jeff scott story to
you guys
he pulled me aside and he said that i
had become a different comic
than when i was there in 2007 and 2006.
he goes i want to do something different
with you from now on he goes you're that
badass of a comic i want you to stick
out this much
i want you to come out to music i'm like
really
he goes yeah but i want you to come out
he goes i know you could dance he goes
i've seen you dance you could dance you
[__] [__]
he goes come out to the bt express come
on and do it
do it do it till you're satisfied right
so
i'm like are you serious so whenever
i would go up that song would start i
don't know if you've ever heard that
song
it's tremendous i'm gonna open up
tuesday morning with it today i'm gonna
open up you i'm gonna you're gonna hear
this song this morning
if you listen to my intro on patreon
it's one of our respect for jeff but i
already used it a couple weeks ago but i
don't give a [__]
this is out of respect for jeff so that
was our song
that was our song and the song starts
off like
so somebody would go coming up to the
stage joey diaz and you were here
and i would go up on stage and dance and
i would go oh [__]
some harvey weinstein music and [__]
they would go bananas
jeff would laugh i would laugh and we'd
have a great time
but it was jeff who pulled me aside and
he goes
you gotta come out to music and [__]
come out [__] rocking and dancing i
was like jeff
if you're telling me because jeff knew
the room
jeff and i had been together since 97 in
that room
and he'll talk to you after i reset he
wasn't a comic
he was a pee wee herman impersonator and
he was fantastic as a pee re herman
impersonator
you ever been a fan of something have
you ever been a fan like
i'm really ashamed in my life that i'm
not a fan of anything
like when you go to the florentine's
house they're a fan of the miami
dolphins
they don't miss a game when when the
team loses they all [__] hurt
you know it's like [__] they throw
things they're a true fan
they're a true fan of the miami dolphins
they love the miami dolphins okay
there's a button i don't i don't give a
[__] who you're a fan of that has
nothing to do with me and our friendship
but
um jeff scott was a real fan of the
comedy store
i don't know if i could explain that to
you he really
enjoyed his job he really
enjoyed the comedians and he really
loved us and every time i saw him
gay or not i gave him a big [__] hug
and i squeezed his ass sometime you know
man i'm [__] crazy with gay guys
i would squeeze his ass and say jeff
your ass is getting too skinny
are you going to get dick if you got
that skinny little boney ass
and he would die a laughter whatever but
uh
jeff was just a good guy and every
tuesday i would go there a little early
and in between the 15 minutes because
all his job to do
was when i went up on stage
when i finished and i'd go coming to the
stage this guy's been on comedy central
mike klein he would play the music like
any like piano music you know
bring like liberace and then you would
go on stage
you know so he would in between that he
would get up
and come outside and smoke pot and talk
to the comics
and then he'd be on a time he'd come
tell me there's two more before you or
three more before you or two more before
you or
what's his name canceled but uh
that's what i remember from jeff man
that he was a sweet guy
and i went online today and i saw so
many [__] people
mention him and i mean he meant a lot to
a lot of people
i've never met anybody
that had a rude word about jeff
or the guy that works in the main room i
forget his name that i've been with him
there for 20 years the sound guy in the
main room
has always been a sweetheart i mean
i look at the comedy store now and i'm
like
every day between you and i lost hope
i don't think it'll ever open again and
i'm happy we went out on top
we went out on top there's no two ways
about it
when we got out of that store february
3rd whenever they closed in march 15th
have no mistakes we were the hottest
club in the [__] country and i was
part of it
and jeff completed that family just
because he played the piano
nobody looked down on him if you ever
said anything to jeff
i think you'd have eight guys on top
you're punching the [__] out of you
and i know me and rogan would be two of
those [__] guys
because that's how much we love jeff
jeff
was that special i can't even imagine
doing comedy now with another different
piano player
because he was there he was my comfort
you know when these idiots get on a
plane with a
a [__] chihuahua with one eye that's
big and like a tooth missing he's my
comfort animal comfort
that's the ugliest [__] animal i've
ever seen in your life you can only
bring comfort to a witch that [__]
thing
he brought comfort to us yeah he brought
comfort to us as a comic so
now i look at the store and i'm like
jesus [__] christ
this is really not going to happen
because
he was the [__] heart and soul of
that place i mean i don't give a [__]
when anybody tells you
bill burr was a big part of it ally wong
was a big part of it
rogan thank god you know dele and his
heyday a lot of people came to see him
uh you know but
jeff scott made it all fit i don't know
how if i could explain that to you when
i go to other comedy clubs in the
country
that's just a dj and that's what the kid
does and he's in nine out of ten
no disrespect any of you guys you're as
dumb as [__]
if joey diaz has a wide audience why are
you playing earth when you fire
you know what i'm saying because they're
so used to many african-american actors
i'm not
ashamed of a baseball fan or anything
but they would not switch they don't
even have common sense you know you see
a bunch of white people coming in
for [__] john mulaney and they got
like the worst rap music on the
back like give me your tits give me your
tits i asked you
yeah yeah no no sometimes they come to
me and they're like
and i would tell them after the first
night knock it off all sabotaged again
sat down
is this sitting down it's sabbath arrow
smith leonard skinner
none of that [__] why you [__] no
[__] rigatone
don't get me in a bad [__] mood that
really tone [__]
oh that [__] drives me [__] crazy it
drives me
[__] crazy but no i don't
uh this this death really
[__] a lot of people up to i've gotten
over 20 calls on it today
people that have been gone from the
store
for 10 years and over call today one guy
called crying
a dear friend of mine he moved back to
boston
10 12 years ago he was like jeff used to
give me piano lessons
i used to go to his house and he'd give
me panelists for 20 miles an hour and
[__] like that
jeff helped so many of us that it was
[__]
it was mind-boggling man so
you know i love peter shaw you know i
love the store i love everything about
it but this is just one more step
of me telling me this the store will
never come back because
he was such an integral part of that
[__] place
i don't know if he could anybody else
could ever take over those shoes
they had another piano guy who was a
cool guy
but he was kind of a pain he asked this
guy i'll tell you what he did one time
hysterical you know you could tell the
guy was in need of [__]
right so what did he do he he went for
the [__] 101 manual
he went and adopted the dog because you
know when you adopt a dog women will
talk to you
oh it's so kind of you you saved the dog
he saved the ugliest dog
you ever seen your [__] life i've
been pulling them all one night going
let me talk to you about something
you haven't gotten [__] in two years
you got a chance to save a good dog
you saved the ugliest [__] dog in the
world and now no chicks want to talk to
you dumb [__]
he only worked on sunday nights so i
only had to put up with him on sundays
on mondays i forget
he worked on an off night jeff worked
all the other nights
what i'm trying to say is rest in peace
jeff thank you
thank you for all those late nights of
being there till 2 2 30 in the morning
thank you for [__] recommending
that music to me i mean and i looked and
i go
why bt express i mean i love this song
i [__] grew up on that jam when i
come on and do it
do it do it till you're satisfied
whatever it is
that's a [__] jam i go what makes you
think of this song he goes i don't know
i heard it the other day and i just
thought about you i thought that you
would come out and kill to it
so rest in peace jeff scott uh all your
years and all your service
were appreciated especially by me there
was a lot of nights i walked in there
and i had my anxiety i had all my other
problems going on
and just seeing your kind smile and give
me a hug and me grabbing your ass
would be worth the trip uh if any fellow
comics watch this
you guys know exactly what i'm talking
about what jeff meant to us
so uh thank you jeff scott rest in peace
and say hello to mitchy for me and i'm
sure with this shitty heart i'll see you
in a couple years and [__] if i
[__] uh don't keep lifting weights
and that's it and that's that brothers
and sisters uh my legs starting to hurt
so uh thank you very much for being
patient with me
um you know i'm waiting on aussies
bonyard dates still
thank you for supporting me you guys
[__] they played the show ten times
because of you [__]
they were supposed to play it five times
that's how much support you
[__] gave me so that's great
i don't know what to tell you
[__] you know i'm sorry about
last week i'm sorry about
you know the pain we're in as like a
country in a way what happened last week
and the whole thing i ain't mad at no
but i'm not here to criticize
anybody when you see a thousand people
walking into the white house that means
anybody can do it
at any time yeah you know
so all i gotta do is come up with 200
yahoos
and i could go to the [__] white
house i would have made a call and i
would have had snipers out there i would
have made a point jack
start picking these [__] off so
nobody ever thinks of [__] doing this
again
nobody ever thinks of doing this [__]
again and i'm not political but that's
the [__] white house
there has to be some respect that's the
capital of our [__] country
there has to be some respect at some
[__] angle here
all those animals walking up the stairs
they were trying to rape nancy pelosi
she got nice titties and [__] but nancy
for a little season [__] rape
she she got nice titties you ever see
those things those things are banging
that [__] makes 25 million dollars a
year
her feet ain't crooked or anything i saw
her feet once her toenails are done
she's still slinging [__] below see the
hair's done
she don't give a [__] nancy pelosi she's
on 60 minutes sunday night
i'm like look at those titties on nancy
pelosi she ain't [__] around
she's 82. those things are harder than
debt i know these are fake
there's 22 year old chicks i wish they
had nancy pelosi's titties
i love you guys thank you very much for
supporting me thank you i'm sorry about
being late with the podcast
we'll be back on wednesday ready to rock
tip top magoo thank you for all the
support
and uh i'll see you on patreon you know
facebook i'm all over the place
i'm like dog [__] i'm everywhere so uh
thank you very much if you're on patreon
enjoy the album of the week
you know we're making it happen over
there three five and ten dollars
what the [__] even netflix is 17 and
what are you gonna do watch [__] they
got 80 shows about pablo escobar
that's what i want to pay for 80 shows
about pablo escobar
oh [__] yourself i love you guys have a
great day thank you for waiting on me
this is because of you
i look good i'm healthy i sound good
it's because the chance you guys
gave me you know i wasn't gonna let it
down i've been taking care of myself
so we're gonna have a great [__] year
together uh uncle vinnie dates are gonna
go up
for february and march i'll let my
patreon people know first
and i'll put the dates on uh twitter
and that's it and that's that i love you
guys have a great day
thank you for everything and rest in
peace jeff scott
you'll be missed you were loved and you
were appreciated trust me when i'm
[__] telling you
thank you enjoy the ads [__]
all right i want to thank you guys i'm
sorry about having the podcast on
tuesday the surgery
slowed me down i wanted to come in here
tip top my goo and i'll give you [__]
[__]
but before i get out of here let's talk
a little bit this weekend
is the playoffs all right you got two or
three games on saturday
two or three on sunday i don't know i
think it's two but it doesn't [__]
matter
what you have on saturday and sunday is
[__] action
what do you got tonight action college
basketball
pro basketball this is the season to be
jolly
and draftkings is here who's draftkings
the top-rated sportsbook
if you haven't tried them yet what the
[__] are you waiting for
to celebrate the nfl playoffs this
weekend draftkings is giving all new
players a great offer
this weekend bet on any football team
hear me out
any football game at 100 to 1 odds did
you hear what i'm saying
a hundred to one odds that's right all
you got to do is bet a [__] dollar on
any football game this weekend
for a chance to win 100 plus the
basketball season is tipped off
so head to the app right now today
tuesday check out
tonight's daily boost if you haven't
signed up yet what the [__] are you
waiting for
now is the time you're just sitting
there in your office all day
you could study you could analyze and
you could play smart
bets not be a [__] savage but first
download the draftking sportsbook app
now
it's safe secure reliable it's your
money
deposit and withdraw at your convenience
download the top-rated draftking
sportsbook app
today not tomorrow right now use promo
code joey when you sign up to get
a hundred to one odds on any football
game this weekend are you [__] crazy
guys
that's code joey j-o-e-y for new players
to get a shot at 100 on any football
action this weekend
for limited time at draftkings
sportsbook now you know the rules
you got to be 21 or older new jersey
indiana pennsylvania
tennessee colorado restrictions apply
see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details
you got a gaming problem there is help
don't put yourself in this hole call
1-800 gambler
and if you're in indiana call one eight
hundred nine with it
but if you don't get no problems and
you're ready to rock and you got a
bankroll
download the draftking sports book app
use code joey and let's make some
[__] money this weekend
the joint is also brought to you by zip
recruiter you're like joey what the [__]
is zip recruiter
zip recruiter is tremendous for a lot of
us our home is our is
more than just our [__] home right
now all right it's an
office in the basement your kids set up
somewhere else in school
your wife is a [__] you know she
wants to be a singer she's singing
[__] arab songs in the basement
you know if you're a business owner you
manage people these days your home might
also be a hiring office
you don't want people coming to the
house that's where zip recruiter comes
in
zip recruiter makes hiring faster and
easier because you could do it all from
one
convenient place la caza that's
ziprecruiter.com
church no matter where you're hiring
from whether you got a small
business or a big [__] company zip
recruiter does the work for you how
zip recruiter has special matching
technology that scans thousands of
resumes
and only sends the most qualified people
for
the job if you're really interested in
the candidate you can invite them to
apply with just one click that's it
zip recruiter sends an email to you and
you stand out from the competition
it's no wonder that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day
you ever try to hire people for a job
they come in they're missing an eye
they're all jacked up
this don't happen with zip recruiter and
right now
try zip recruiter for free f-r-e-e
free at ziprecluded.com church
that's ziprecruiter.com church
c-h-u-r-c-h
all you need is a wi-fi to try it for
free that's it
go to zipperclip.com right now slash
church
it's the smartest way to hire especially
in these times
the joint is also brought to you by
listen i can't say a lot
enough good things about it you guys
have been following me
know they've been around forever every
two weeks
i got a new guy trying to send me cbd
products and i'll be honest with you
nothing matches up the cbd line when i
tell you nothing
nothing from the roll on to the gummies
to the kinesiology tape
to the back balls to the tincture which
is [__] phenomenal
that listen vapor pen if you got an
ailment
go to cbdlion.com read the website look
at the third party live results
why are you wasting your time buying it
at some [__] shoe store
or some [__] liquor store from some
chick we don't know dick from dick
cbd lion is the way to go you understand
me
press in code joey or church and get 20
off delivered to your [__] house it's
that simple all right
i'll see you guys on [__] wednesday
stay black
thank you for supporting me and my knee
is alive and kicking i'm ready to rock
stay black
there you go the candles on lick
[Music]
[__]
you